The,
the,
the argument that,
uh,
I think,
taking on cuttings because last point
about when countries become independent,
I think this is something that a Russian
politicians says,
Oregon complaining about saying that,
oh,
this is the walls was a bloke mentality.
Those people hate us and they actually
created more problems in a relationship
with Europe because they became
independent and they're trying to play
their own political games and gaming
internationalism.
I think that a lot of that will depend
on whether they will actually shale gas
development in the foreseeable future in
those countries that you mentioned
because I think that Russians really
have the capacity to act quite quickly.
And as I said earlier,
there is a lot of pressure now.
I'm particularly from a company such as
Nova Tech,
but also from the Russian oil,
oil companies,
particular Rosneft to um,
which is moving into gas business very
actively,
very actively.
And they could potentially displace
Gazprom to a certain degree.
It was in Russia and also externally.
So,
um,
I don't know.
I think that,
um,
it's often difficult to make
predictions.
Your question is it related to 10 years,
20 years,
30 years,
40 years,
but when we look at this aspect to
remember about all this forecast,
what we're talking about,
if you look at the,
the latest they're talking about 20,
35,
$24.
So by looking but you know,
20,
30 years ahead,
look at what we're now in year 19,
20,
20 slash 30 years.
What has happened in the world.
So I think this is,
this is an important point that the
world is changing and a very fast pace
and I think that a lot of this,
a lot of this,
a forecast and predictions are just,
I'm just a guide for us to
base our decisions.